5 13 on your wednesday morning what's
cool at school how about a local junior
high school celebrating a big birthday
with an old-fashioned county fair
[Applause]
hundreds of students and their families
converged on the campus of the ko
knutson academy of the arts
not just to sing happy birthday for the
school's 60th jubilee
there were performances all around
including
mariachi
[Music]
dance
band
and
orchestra the cafeteria became the
concession stand where freshly made
cotton candy was a big hit so was the
photo booth with ko's tv production
teacher heather rampton it's great
hanging out with magnet coordinator
shantae johnson and the choir director
amy sims and art teacher shawn jones
speaking of art part of the gym was a
showcase for student art
and so was one of the sidewalks
so my thanks to the principals leslie
kepp for inviting me shout out to the
thousands of successful las vegas who
have spent some of their precious
teenage years down through the decades
at the now 60 year old ko knudsen
academy of the arts now if you know
something cool at school let us know
head over to uh 8newsnow.com click on
cool at school under the community tab
or just send us an email coolantschool
eight newsnow.com it was so much fun it
was like a carnival atmosphere they had
the ring toss they had the basketball
there was it felt like you were the kind
of cotton candy yes they did
hot dogs popcorn
nachos it was great
quite a celebration good for them happy
birthday